wanna be the hero of your own fantasy
entered the epic world of ttle area
where Dark Elves meet the sacred order
and the banner Lords are an endless war
with the undead hordes collect equipped
train and upgrade your team of heroes in
order to start a journey of a lifetime
raid shadow legends oh sorry
raid is a dark fantasy RPG which is
available on PC mobiles and is also
cross-device I have a lot of dog funder
C's we know and the best part about raid
is it's completely free to play what is
free nowadays challenge yourself to the
edge in ongoing tournaments compete
against the entire raid community while
fighting the spiders Den ice golem speak
the almighty fire night or the no
vitória stock color no it's a dragon
lightly more powerful than Connor well
yeah left hook fire I think we should go
through a little bit of gameplay so when
you first log into the game you'll see
this and what you want to do is click
battle in the bottom right corner so the
two champions I've got for this art
garlic and sniper I tell you what I'm
feeling lucky
I don't usually start with this but I
feel like we need to make a statement
we're gonna go with Hellraiser see how
much damage that caused straightaway
look at this little ginger [__] that's
not me saying that that's garlic he can
say that he's ginger too
there we go are you tired once ooh
victory that was pretty easy to be fair
I'm gonna summon something and we've got
Wow a new champion etched as I
pronounced it next I'm always so
impressed at how detailed the graphics
are it's a good game and it reminds me
of some of the old-school RPG I used to
play as a kid so there's an a star to
value there do want anywhere tell her
about the updates and now in read patch
1 15 update is coming in May and with it
you will be able to compete in the brand
new arena tournament earn points
according to your tier and win awesome
rewards and the local and global
tournament so what you waiting for go to
the link in the description and download
rage header legends and if you're a new
player you'll be rewarded with 100k
silver and this free epic champion
grumbler how does grumblers be and make
you feel about your beard I mean you
can't pop the inferior really there's a
manly beard God Almighty if that's
what's on his chin then what's between
his legs you'll find these rewards here
in your inbox for the next 30 days only
so hurry up and don't forget you can
find me under the nickname
giotto out there so hit the download
button guys obviously they support us to
help us pay for the videos you download
the game you play the game that's how it
works
really appreciate everyone who supports
read
again for raid sponsoring this video
what comes to mind when you think of
classic YouTube would have been
classically all the ones he paved the
way one of the first guys I watch was
Bob you two known it okay he's up there
definitely him falling into a pool but
he was super heavy do you remember when
you first saw this video it was about
2013 was there a friend that sent me the
video or what was recommended because I
found buggy because I was really into
the gaming stuff okay PlayStation and
yeah do a lot of those videos yes who
would you consider the founding fathers
of YouTube to me though not the reality
the hodgetwins I actually was a big fan
of the hodgetwins back and it wasn't
yeah amen
hey Amy you don't build some muscle man
looking bills from awesome I forgot the
wait wait so anyways I want to take you
on a journey to some of the classic
youtubers from my childhood this is
worrying because I think YouTube in 2020
[__] so God knows how should it was but
then you must have seen this you have
seen this know this guy he's still there
pretty well he's lasted doesn't it yeah
picabo's do an extent he's got a place
on the Hall of Fame so for those who
don't know this is copper cap one of my
favorite bits is where it goes you had
God you don't scare me always used to
get me it really irritates me South part
would say that red haired people don't
have soules okay because we do we do
have souls alright at this point you
feel sorry for him and there's nothing
that said this is a joke you think don't
this was real and then he bounced off of
Italy until [__] it I'll make I'll make
the most out of it well the thing is
he's personality now is so crazy that
you think it is real yeah I've seen him
in like UFC Octagon sort of what
training and then for a period of time
you said that he was totally yeah woman
yeah no he did and that was like bite
worldwide news that you thought was
[__] as well he went back in
patrolling this guy's like an ultimate
role teachers have souls
I got a church I'm a Christian you don't
know me you're not God hmm you're not
God so this video is some three months
ago and it's entitled Ginger's still
have so
I just wanted to say that it still
irritates me that South Park says that
gingers don't have salt because we do we
do if it's quite familiar can't leave
our fingers on month I think so Ginger's
the thing is if you go on making loads
of videos acting like this it gets to
the point where it becomes your actual
personality and I think that's what
we're seeing here there's a phrase in
the W Dory well called living the
gimmick okay but at some point like
Stone Cold Steve Austin and the like
start they get carried away with it this
guy is definitely living the gimmick
yeah he's caught my cab 2470 have you
ever heard of a youtuber known as Fred
no okay Fred Brian was the first channel
to reach 1 million subscribers and
they'd be like really good or something
was a lot better than everyone else you
can be the judge of that
this is do you think that Fred will be
as successful if he came on YouTube now
well this is the thing this is [__] but
there are worse videos now that get
millions of views as well Oh 76 million
views yes Scott this was one of his most
popular videos there's every video on
every video that's his character
[Music]
change
just think if you made the podcast in
2008 these are the kind of guess you
would have asked I mean look at the
views Brian 39 million views the other
video look 25 million 21 million I
remember back in the day he was like the
top of the top I'm so like blown away
about this he had like three Nickelodeon
films it's not exactly Scarface is it
people will do anything for money on
this at a time this is how mainstream
viewed YouTube this I need to say what
he's like now okay about the voice and
how he's grown alright so his real name
how many years ago ten years ago it's
just ten years ago I need to see him not
less he's still getting 100 - couple
hundred clear views yeah I think a lot
of people follow him now only for the
nostalgia value though I wonder if one
day that'll be like me you know he used
to be good I mean I thought it was good
not like not that it's you know anything
to pick up on deliberately it just
scared I went off there okay what was
the giveaway I don't know how to put it
but he's got quite a lot sort of
friendly boyish face yeah and ten years
on after doing all that you'd have
thought he would have I was expecting
him to be a bit more of a drug addict
okay
like I thought you'd probably cobia you
just look like all of the signs and
those early Fred videos give the sense
of Disney star going crazy absolutely
yeah like have you seen Tom Green Tom
Green oh my god
[Music]
back in the day a guy called Tom Green
who had his orden mundial shirt he was a
comedian and decided to take his own
life show started up in his own house
broadcasting on his website no one was
doing he had servos built in his house
okay so he was a youtuber preachy but
yeah there was no such thing so when
YouTube came along instead of it I'll
just keep doing my own thing really if
he jumped on YouTube then it would have
been a star it would have been the
biggest thing on YouTube Wow from day
one yeah how'd as you can see we had Joe
Rogan on his show this YouTube had
already started then yeah and Jorah was
just sort of coming to those ideas of
I'm gonna do a podcast yeah the first
night we did Skype it was just so
awesome Bob Saget was here and Max
Miller was the caller in New York he
just you're connected you connected it
really is different you know and
television this is way better so this is
when Skype had just started okay and he
was setting up Skype calls on the show
and doing what we can do like that now
but no one had done that yeah television
the thing that [__] up entertainment
in general is money they were selling
advertising so everybody has to say
certain words don't say certain words
don't bring up certain subjects you you
can't just express yourself because
you're expressing yourself to someone
who's selling advertising space and
that's all in that [__] up everything
it doesn't doesn't make anything good we
need a [__] up advertiser around here
that's all we need to figure out how you
make money from this yeah this is unreal
isn't it Joe Rogan sitting there going
we need to think about how we could make
money from this and now look he's
actually breaking records is the most
paid podcaster in the world they have
mass markers they're talking about the
idea of television in different mediums
being regulated by Ofcom and things like
that where you can't get sponsors yeah
if you're not doing clean TV
fast forward however many years ago this
was 20 2007 now we've got it exactly but
that's also the same time we are being
regulated in a different way because it
used to be a point where you could say
anything and do whatever you want it's
gone back though yeah and backwards no I
just think I remember
during this 126 million views Brian you
need to make songs on the YouTube
channel music it's work more for care so
why not let me paint a very deep voice
for such a little sort of regular look
in case the rain droplet rooms they dry
in others feel the pain yeah the thing
is you've never expressed these it's all
expressions really like he's mid-stroke
126 million views could you imagine a
video like this nowadays getting
anywhere close to that it's got a good
voice in terms of yeah he does works for
that song in baritone what's he doing
now that's what I always find
fascinating
[Music]
why are all these young youtubers from
the past all gay no doesn't say he was
gay what was the tell-tale sign he was
gay that's a very straight heart Brian I
love you know look every video isn't
gonna be any judge kinky ostrich
obviously I don't give a [__] either way
but it's interesting
okay you guys coming across that
effeminate you know maybe it's Ted like
the combination of the leather jacket
and it's the leather on the heart and
then the deliberate undone okay there's
a lot of effort gone in here more effort
than straight men usually make maybe
obviously I'm generalizing there the way
I see it he's Italian and it's a way of
saying well the way he looks at Italian
man-to-man
one thing I'm realizing is his voice
only work for that one song and it
actually doesn't fit other song exactly
I know he is the definition of a one-hit
wonder so most of the big youtubers back
then are now irrelevant yeah I think one
of the only youtubers that has managed
to survive through the years is Shane
Dawson now Shane Dawson does very
different contents of the content that
they used today I want to say this all
[__] I've never seen that really hey
game ik balls face why don't you leave
some for the Turtles oh good wine yeah
I've been working on that one for a
while just a sec all yours I think she's
so cool cuz yes we'll be emo hair and
wears tight pants a show off his
rock-hard ass what nothing this is the
14 Dawson came out as gay as well really
so yeah two people think he wasn't gay I
think he had a girlfriend no you did
have a girlfriend Shane Dawson had a
girlfriend called Lisa Schwartz for a
long period of time can I see her yeah
we're outside and we're pissing off our
neighbors this blows my mind
because I've only ever known the sky as
gay chain dogs yeah yeah and I've not
been at this thing like was he unsure
about then was this just maybe there's a
cover-up I don't know he always had a
bit of a camp element to it
abso-fucking-lutely and then he came as
by I don't know if he's still by his
Gayle he's been with a man for a long
time Joe yes
I'm only giggling a little bit because
he just had the boyfriend challenge and
in my head I'm like what you wanna get
one boy your way possible yeah it's like
the boyfriend challenge the elephant was
in the room obviously the breaker video
was that was there a break yeah I don't
think he was a very destructive breakup
he's very much like they'll david dobrik
lies a cosy situation where I think they
both just so spoke about each other sort
of pretend like that's [__] yeah in a
light-hearted way it wasn't like I
[__] hate him and all this stuff
what's your favorite YouTube brick or
video has to be the David Oprah wanna
know Alex Kollek solder for me like Alex
day that was just a ripoff of the david
dobrik
oh it was no offense leave calyx alone I
have been extremely sexually confused
and I mean my whole life but this last
year is when it really hit me I always
wish that I was gay that I was just a
hundred percent gay for so many reasons
you know number one that means I would
know who I was there's not many
youtubers I can just speak from the
heart like this do you believe every
word of this yeah I saw that we do
there's no question in my head that this
is the truth he's so real that it just
shows that like real people are
successful on YouTube if they stick to
who they are a lot of people play up to
an axe on YouTube don't they what are
the mistakes people make though from
what I've seen on YouTube as they go oh
you've changed
you're fake now because you used to be
like this but now you're like that so
now you're fake and a lot of people who
say that don't understand that the
majority of people when they start
YouTube to when they get to their peak
like 10 years from 20 to 30 in my
opinion is the biggest change that
you'll ever go through in your life in
terms of like you go from being a child
to an adult you're finding out who you
are you go through this whirring hoop
what people think - eventually going on
my bracing that and you can see Shane's
done that I feel for him having to do
this and it's like it's good to say this
it's important but if you look at the
other classic eg bits known of them
could really evolve you know one-trick
ponies they could only stay with what
they had and they didn't becomes I'll
just kind of selling [__] makeup like
to millions well yeah because Shane was
like himself and he didn't care about
change in any you know in terms of
youtubers who I'd really want to
interview because they've got something
to say and I'm intra and I really want
to like find out about them he's on that
list for sure okay so this is another
classic YouTube video black man angry at
KFC hello sir would you like some of our
delicious chicken no [__] I'm in here
to lick one of your titties of course I
want some damn delicious chicken laughs
what I'm inside so this guy was almost a
food review at the for food review he's
a bit mendel him isn't he well that's
why it's called black man angry at KFC
back in the day I used to love this
guy's videos I remember once I emailed
him
that's funnier than the actual video
what did you email all right so far the
email I said to this guy this is Becky
this is like around the time he made
probably when you sent this it says an
email here d6 I am 13 years old right
now I am just is I am without a space
between it from the UK did he pass
English and I've only been watching your
videos for a few months now when I saw
your video about your childhood and
growing up it made me sad to think what
a great man like you
this guy's a great man it's great man
right yeah ladies what a great man like
you would have gone through some
terrible stuff but it also inspired me
even more to be a better person and be
more positive about myself this is my
inspiration this guy was my hero I'm
writing this to let you know to never
stop making YouTube videos and always
look ahead with your head held high
because one day when you're a
millionaire comedian it will hold video
can we just we just find out if he's a
millionaire Kimmy 17k views 6k views I
told you secure millionaire there's
nothing wrong with giving a little bit
positivity I mean you must get emails
all that quite a lot of people that have
locked up to you inside with a video to
touch them in a certain way you know
stuff like that there's some positive
stuff exactly some some positives okay
so this is a nice condition I am so
relaxed right now as well you picked the
perfect time because I'm just like it's
sunny outside you don't have a beard a
drink and it's locked down nothing
better to do I'm gonna feel really nice
to relax and enjoy this yeah a meanwhile
so we spoke before about a lot of the
popular trends on YouTube and the
Internet as a whole having their
foundations in the classic era one of
the most popular things at the moment
are Eagles
if you Grande more so what's an eagle
how would you describe it well it's
simply a female personality that I think
buys into male attention
right I like
okay the obviously have to be female and
they have to be quite alluring yes you
have to use their womanly traits - yeah
- bring in male viewership and male
money I got a lot of flack for support
and giving a little RINO people said I
was really harsh because I was joking
about the fact that she played that boy
yeah what scar us and I was obviously
joking about that but some people were
like [__] about it but in my head it's
like you are as a man getting involved
with an eagle constantly under threat
you have to defend that territory at all
times when you're sleeping there in
those two M's there's always someone
giving her the attention and the minute
that you're not there that give that
attention so she's getting it covered by
someone else and if she isn't that loyal
girl and Eagles can be loyal but by
nature they enjoy our attention you got
to know what the [__] you're dealing
with and if you own a Rottweiler yeah
maybe comparing it with the point is you
got to know what you're dealing with
don't be surprised when it backfires
yes that was my point yeah have you
heard of the okay boomer girl she's this
of the newest a girl that's emerged I've
heard the obviously the term Walker boom
oh okay one who smoked with it she
didn't come up with it but she's become
popular recently for this video
[Music]
what do you think why was it popular I
think people just like her looks really
okay yeah I think that's it but it's a
very specific type of people it's
basically the computer is we love you
and they become obsessed with these
girls and stuff and they look up to them
and worship them one off to them
basically is there a channel can we see
a channel is there a channel is your
type Brian got star quality if you walk
down the street and she walked past you
as a man you could not ignore
that's own ignore Apple yeah in exactly
and that's not walking down the street
so this girl's online she looks like a
month of people every day Ciaran swear
and she's in a unique position because
she's in a position where she's got a
lot of male attention so this could go
either way though I think it's important
she got some good advice right now cuz
everything I'm saying she's not showing
too much so she can go down a classic
road where she tries to be taken
seriously yeah or she can start and only
funds exactly it's almost like a tease
culture isn't it yeah so this male
attention in this tease culture thing is
converted into money by the way that
they get people to donate on streams and
there was another very famous eco Belle
Delphine she sold her own bathwater I've
seen will donated a lot to her she saw
thousands of it sure saw the business in
it this is how my brain works these
girls I rather my money my time and my
attention into a girl who equally wants
me but okay right like no offense but
these girls they don't give a [__] about
you boys there's real women out there
who'll touch your back who will look at
you in the eye and actually look after
you make your son much make no mistake
about it they don't give a [__] about
you you're a name on a screen with a few
numbers afterwards and a dollar sight
like don't let me wrong I'm not gonna go
to the girls do your household and get
the money making a lot money I'm game
like you know I get it you gotta make
your money and white before you're 40
you got as much cash do you call these
guys don't want to go out there and like
try and pursue women they'd rather just
sit in and watch this girl and don't
like
[__] life like there are real women
out there who also could do with some
attention and probably would like your
company and maybe if you got your sorry
ass off the couch and actually took one
of them out you would realize that your
waist and your [__] time trying to
get her attention she is gonna end up
with a baller a basketball player
probably is gonna fall and be married to
this girl we got a chance as normal guys
we've got a [__] prey so get that out
your [__] head I found my favorite my
favorite videos so far bro juggle right
well get back on truck it's been fun I
don't ever tons in there but this video
ultimately is about the classic
youtubers so I wanted to show you these
because what I'm about to show you is
the original ego boxy
[Music]
this box is boring and she yeah but she
was the original this is 23 million
views and this was the start no boxy
there would be no Nikko load to be no
bail Delphine because she started the
first restart just being younger and
cute the ego idea so then all the guys
online these like simple guys online
became obsessed with it they're just
flow yes immature is a common
characteristic with all the egos whether
it be Belle Delphine boxy or Nico
they have like a childish or personality
not feeling that no I like it yeah I
think it's to make some men out there
feel like the big dominant one yeah you
know and it's it's done cleverly to play
up to the ego of men exactly you don't
have to do that these girls have
discovered what the Internet's type is
yeah basically and they're playing on
men stereotype they're making a lot of
money but boxy was the OG so Fair Play
alright so nowadays Brian porn stars are
all over YouTube I mean my cuts a
different one on every other month yeah
but it used to be a time on YouTube by
the only time you'd see a porn star was
on custom g-series going deep welcome to
another episode of going deep I'm your
host Kassem G with me today is adult
actress Stella
worry the fact that he looked and read
it
was in front of imaginated on but twist
me today is Tyson Fury hello
Tyson hello Stella how are you Oh God so
this is a little person it is yes she's
a porn star not your normal pawn so
she's not know obviously she's a little
person but but just generally amuse
Aneesh I'm actually fascinated to see
how on earth she manages this you know a
few moments later I mean why would I
want to see our fate the weirdest thing
about all of this it's not the fact that
she's a little person it's a face as she
pulled up right you see that face thing
it's pretty much exactly like the face
that we've just been watching on that
video bizarre are you more attracted to
a regular person there's one person who
could recreate that and do it better
than him it's Lawrence oh yeah yeah
Lawrence is dead pardon is just like
unbeatable pianist Lee so I'm gonna say
a word and you just say the first word
that comes to your head okay Batman sexy
ninja I see a Viper
scary Colossus thank what do all those
words have in common
sighs those are all names of rides
roller coasters that you'll never be
able to get on yeah of all the [__]
YouTube as you've ever shown me from the
classic list this [__] is by a
mile the funniest sofa Casa me Jake
wonder if you could sit in my lap and we
could do a routine okay are you sure you
want me to send you out oh I'm sure
every time I tap on you you move your
mouth okay
I always love it when someone is just
willing across the [__] like oh yeah
it's absolutely this guy no boundaries
what it makes what I see [__] like this
it makes me realize how affected I've
been by the PC culture what custom do
you'll get slammed on making these kind
of videos now but the thing is though in
context it's funny yeah he's he's not
poking fun at someone who isn't in on
the joke she's clearly in on the joke
yeah right and that's that's why like
Gervase when he does stuff like that was
Warwick Davis it's funny I did this sort
of [__] just makes me wanna push it
further on my own stuff do you know no
me but yeah I gotta pay the bills on me
I can't believe he did this
no this is for me have you ever heard of
Epic Meal Time by any chance no I think
this is a channel you'll like Epic Meal
Time was basically a group of people
that used to make really eccentric food
items out of loads of other different
foods no ripping off strips and that
bacon it
trained by the tray all day onions thank
you for that customer
stop I'm really interested to see where
this is Gordon you got me interested
that's the burger Bates Baconator layer
player more bacon strips pack it in the
team burgers the middle chat what the
[__] am i watching does not make you
hungry
not really you know when people share
this sort of [__] on my Facebook or
Twitter or WA yeah I've always been like
what's wrong with just a normal plate of
nice food like why do you have to make
something that's industrial sized for me
the big other portion the more that can
go wrong so that does not look
appetizing in I would have thought that
you would have enjoyed being there with
them and me in an that no no I wouldn't
eat that all right for the length of
time it's taken out the coop that these
Big Macs in there would have gotten
[__] stonewalled for start and then
they've reheated them again and they've
piled on a lot of what mints and and and
[__] bacon and cheese and all of a
sudden lasagna this is shy yeah whatever
you invite your outer they made this
your Bryant we meet some festival
lasagna drove it no [__] with that
I've washed up dude in the toilet it's
disgusting if I want lasagna okay I'll
have a nice lasagna whatever lasagna
with Big Macs and bacon in sauce and
cheese I've got no idea what this is
that would be something you'd put in a
bucket of slops and feed it to the pigs
that's the same you don't like this
concept because I think that you'd be a
good host for the UK's answer to this
you could bring it back
Jordi Meal Time I wouldn't mind doing
some cookin but this is just this is
next-level
okay so let's go back to PewDiePie's
earliest videos how's it going everyone
here welcome to my very first non
gameplay video it's gonna be a really
boring video just warning you but it's
also an important video because I have
some things that I need to say what do
you reckon a pity party what do you make
of I like him more now I think because
now we saw sarcastic in you know funny
back then he just seemed a bit obviously
wasn't natural in front of the camera
but then he was you doing he first
started so he was also becoming the guy
I suppose that he was gonna be rules new
it's weird not watching him be a
sarcastic bastard because now that's all
he does really my name's
five and welcome to Franny I hope you
like that intro it's made by the red
when you consider house [__] he is on
camera how not funny he is there no
Emily was never funny yeah but right
there charismatic Alice you know if like
that is even or how good he is on camera
now it's quite amazing yes he is so good
on cop then again he said years at the
top I disagree there are some people
when you look back at them ten years
we'll do the barely level up they pay
leak ever he has gotten so much better
yeah one of the funniest guys on YouTube
do you understand how PewDiePie is
consistently gained in millions of
subscribers every month there's three
reasons for it number one reason in the
past year was his rivalry with the is he
serious yeah that clearly made people
want him to win yes other people just so
big-name just for the sake of them not
being number one secondly when you first
join YouTube everyone knows who's the
weakest guy in YouTube okay it's him
alright I'll follow him then and thirty
years good yeah he's great
so I guess there's the three reason I
guess that makes sense
he really doesn't seem to give a [__]
about like the money the fame like he
doesn't seem to give a [__] about any of
that
yeah even though he is rich so it's
probably a good thing he is the guy when
PewDiePie changed his style and it
became the sarcastic bastard he is now a
lot of people said that he was copying a
youtuber called filthy Frank you know
who filthy Frank is I've heard of them
because people say Brody's a bit like
that you know what filthy for
[Music]
all right we [__] gay there's got to
be a point but even the pros are like
we're taking this to new levels right
this is mango anyway so they make
basically make a cake out of hair
shaving the eyebrows and everything it
looks like a mental patient this oh my
god yes run Sedona it's just ugly though
so during the years of 2015-2016
channels like thrived before you two
realized advertising companies might not
want to pay for that the one thing that
comes across about all of this is like
ug was heading down such as a safe PC
road that people like this just are
gonna be a thing of the past this was
the last hoorah of the crazy of YouTube
yeah [__] look like filthy Frank now
can't make the same kind of videos that
he wants this is rusev sure look he just
music now do you not know he goes by the
name Joe gee it was assumed this is him
swirl oh I swear my life this is him
this is a filthy for right now
[Music]
this is Phil Feith from this is filthy
Frank now that isn't bad no it was great
this and that we might revisit this yeah
I think there's a lot we can done
there's probably a lot that I don't know
that's not so I'm learning turns out I
don't know everything yeah that's a tip
of the iceberg in terms of classic eg
mushroom too so if anyone has any
suggestions for other classic youtubers
or YouTube videos that we could react to
in another video let us know in the
comments comment below
I don't usually encourage that for go
ahead put the links in as well because I
we can't be asked to research everything
no Cheers